[Music]
all right this is great news a date has
been set the Inspector General Michael
Horowitz he anticipates the release of
his all-important report hasn't gone on
18 months the date is set for next
Thursday one week from tonight June the
14th for weeks we have been predicting
that these findings would in fact be
buried and released when all eyes would
be fixed on the president's historic
meetings in Singapore sadly I think my
prediction was somewhat right and it's
only two days after this big summit
takes place and then of course this will
be released now what is the Justice
Department potentially redacted or
change because they've had it for over
two weeks now
did they alter any language how will the
American people will they get the truth
in all this will they be prevented from
seeing the truth in other words are we
really going to get unfettered contents
of inspector general Horowitz's report
now make no mistake
next Thursday right here on Hannity we
will be analyzing that forthcoming
report page by page on what will be one
of the most consequential days in modern
history that's two days of course after
the summit sorry I am suspicious and I
hopefully Stan will stand corrected next
week now we do have one good development
to report tonight the inspector general
Horowitz is now set to testify before
the Senate the Monday following the
Thursday release and of course all of
this on the heels of what is now a
non-stop effort that we have seen by
Congress and by the Department of
Justice to Congress to obstruct Congress
from doing its constitutional duty and
that is oversight in their
investigations and a quarter - according
to Senator Grassley's office the DOJ is
now refusing to make documents and at
least one witness available for their
oversight into the FBI's ongoing general
Flint investigation and add to this the
DOJ is constant slow walking of those
documents to all the House committees
the House Intelligence Committee the
oversight committees Sarah Carter will
tell you all about a huge fight that
took place earlier today and how the DOJ
has reneged this morning on a previous
commitment to supply documents that are
related to the Russia investigation the
big battle it ended up the Department
justice now adding unprecedented new
restrictions on how it plans to brief
members of Congress we're gonna have
more on this very important story
what we need is of course youth the
American people to be able to see it for
yourself and yesterday we reported on
how the Deputy Attorney General rod
Rosenstein arrogantly rebuffed Senator
Lindsey Graham and his letter demanding
to know why the head of the Moller
investigation has not refused himself
given his numerous conflicts of interest
including his key role in that decision
of fire James Comey he's witnessed
number one in that case and of course he
was the person that signed off on the
third subsequent renewal application as
it relates to the FISA warrant that of
course spying on a trump campaign
associate senator Graham is responding
let's take a look were you satisfied
with the response from the Justice
Department to inquiry about whether rod
was a scientific ears no well you talk
about a counterintelligence
investigation I get that the question is
the instructions to justice by firing
Comey how you can have that discussion
without calling us an mo he's a fine guy
I got nothing against him I think he's
doing a good job you know I understand
what jeff Sessions can't do this I'm
really curious as to how Rosen Stein
could be involved in overseeing an
investigation is going to be
well have a lot more on this hole
throughout the show tonight but first we
have another extremely bit of important
news to cover first and foremost the
president's historic impending trip to
Singapore just days away from holding
these talks with the North Korean
dictator Kim jong-un and they are going
to talk about the complete and total D
nuclearization of the Korean Peninsula
all of that is on the line earlier today
the president gave a preview of this
upcoming trip here's what he had to say
I hope the upcoming meeting in Singapore
represents the beginning of a bright new
future for North Korea and indeed a
bright new future for the world the
denuclearization of the Korean Peninsula
would usher in a new era of prosperity
security and peace for all Koreans north
and south and for people everywhere we
could absolutely sign an agreement we're
looking at it we're talking about it
with them we're talking about it with a
lot of other people but that could
happen but that's really the beginning
sounds a little bit strange but that's
probably the easy part the hard part
remains after that maximum pressure is
absolutely in effect we don't use the
term anymore because we're going into a
friendly negotiation
perhaps after that negotiation I will be
using it again
you'll know how well we do with the
negotiation if you hear me saying we're
going to use maximum pressure you'll
know the negotiation did not do well if
the summit does go well will you mean
inviting North Korean leader Kim jong-un
to the United States well the answer is
yes to the second part of your question
but certainly if he goes well and I
think it would be well-received I think
he would look at it very favorably so I
think that could happen all I can say is
I am totally prepared to walk away I did
it once before you have to be able to
walk away I really believe that we have
the potential to do something incredible
for the world and it's my honor to be
involved and the Secretary of State Mike
Pompeo who's played a very important
role in North Korea in these discussions
and the lead-up to all of this
weighed in on these upcoming talks let's
take a look the fact that our two
leaders are coming to the table shows
that the two sides are very serious the
diplomatic model used to date is
different from past efforts our efforts
give us hope that we can find real
success for past efforts have fallen
short President Trump is hopeful but
he's also going into the summit with his
eyes wide open we've seen how many
inadequate agreements have been struck
in the past and you can be sure the
President Trump will not stand for a bad
deal here we are only days away from
diplomatic progress the former President
Obama frankly only dreamed of majority
of Americans how are they responding
overwhelmingly now supporting the
president's upcoming summit now all of
this after the mainstream media doubted
they were fear-mongering talks of
nuclear war and in a sad way I think
many because they don't like President
Trump and they want the Democrats to win
actually even rooting against the
president's success here that's sad for
the country take a look the idea of a
nuclear showdown with North Korea keeps
you up at night I would recommend
deleting your Twitter app he is not
merely being cavalier with a threat
about nuclear war he's being cavalier
in a way that it makes him seem demented
these are the messages from a person who
is not well from a leader who is not fit
for office president Trump is goading
Kim jong-un to test a nuclear missile
again to prove its reliability to show
him wrong and fundamentally I think it
comes across as two kindergarteners who
are jostling each other except that each
has nuclear weapons hundred thousand
Americans die absolu clear Holocaust or
after a million die that's where we are
this is not an exaggeration Trump's
comments about nuclear weapons have
experts worried he could literally
inadvertently trigger a catastrophe
Wow could trigger catastrophe typical
conspiracy theory over there
all right these nuclear tests so far
let's go through this no more missiles
being fired over Japan Guam's not being
threatened the region's not being
threatened oh we do have three American
hostages thank God they are home they
have been
and what you just saw was obviously fake
news we watch Kim jong-un walk across
the DMZ right into the arms of the South
Korean president and the dismantling of
one of his nuclear test sites now
because this is just the first of three
egregious examples of fake news we're
going to highlight tonight
all right here's number two over there
conspiracy TV MSNBC ego liberal Joe and
Mika they can't help themselves
now usually Mika spends her mornings
pushing untrue absurd theories about the
president's mental health with of course
Joe Scarborough who's now the liberal
but today she actually ventured out on
her own
and floated this insane rumor I'll tell
you a couple of things first of all the
hypocrisy is astounding because I know
someone who spoke to Donald Trump
recently about life in the White House
and Donald Trump's biggest complaint was
that he's not allowed to watch porn in
the White House he's upset that he can't
watch porn in the White House I bet they
have those you know one 900 numbers
block to which must be a disappointment
I'm not really sure but that's it just
sort of flies in the face of all of this
and ELAC are you proud of that is this
what is so-called news over there 30
rock this is so insane honestly I can't
even bother alright let's go to our
third and almost unbelievable example of
fake news it does involve yours truly
last night right here on this program
yesterday on my radio show I made what
are obviously sarcastic remarks
highlighting a clear double standard as
it relates to our justice system equal
justice under the law equal application
of our nation's law laws that I was
talking about Hillary Clinton and
comparing her than what she did to those
that have been targeted by Muller's
witch-hunt as Muller is requesting
everybody's phones how interesting
watch this baby mullahs witnesses I
don't know if I advise them to follow
Hillary Clinton's lead delete all your
emails and then acid-wash the emails and
hard drives on the new phones then take
your phones and
bash them with a hammer two little
itsy-bitsy pieces use bleach pit remove
the SIM cards and then take the pieces
and hand it over to robert muller and
say Hillary Rodham Clinton Clinton this
is equal justice under the law how do
you think that would work out for
everybody who mo is demanding their
phones up tonight now I'm certain the
result would not be the same as
Hillary's other once everyone's cell
phones my advice to them not really
kidding bad advice would be follow
Hillary's you know leave not really
kidding bad advice and I said if words
actually matter if I told them now
believe it or not the insane left-wing
media in this country headline after
headline they picked up those comments
they're so dumb and gullible and had a
full on the only I can describe as a as
a fake news freakout look at Newsweek
Sean Hannity's advice to Muller
witnesses pass your phones with a hammer
Rolling Stone went with the headline
galaxy brain Sean Hannity advises Muller
targets to smash their cell phones from
the business insider sean hannity
suggests muller probe witnesses should
destroy their evidence and more fake
news from the daily costs sean hannity
breaks the law on TV telling muller
probe witnesses to destroy evidence in
this Vanity Fair he goes on and on Trump
Sean Hannity Trump associates you're not
obstructing just as hard enough the
liberal Daily Beast Sean Hannity two
witnesses a Muller probe bash your
phones into pieces GQ they got into the
game Sean Hannity encourages Muller
witnesses to do even more crimes than
they may have already committed and I
can go on frankly for another twenty
minutes here but the hysteria gets even
worse let's take a look at how Andy
lacks network to handle this Sean
Hannity is now literally telling
potential witnesses and subjects in the
Muller probe to destroy the evidence and
hammer their phones into pieces the
Hannity's defenders make all that
sarcasm or poetic license but words are
words Sean Hannity lives off his words
and we all know they have a huge
in fact if anyone actually does what
Sean Hannity says there they'd be
committing a crime what Sean Hannity
admitted to it actually was enticing
people to do and asking them to do was
to destroy evidence which is a violation
of the witness tampering statute no
responsible person on television no
responsible so-called journalist should
be advocating for people to destroy
evidence in a serious federal
investigation I don't think that we'll
see him prosecuted
federal prosecutors give people a very
wide berth on First Amendment related
conduct and so unless there's something
more specific to link it up I think that
this will be what we often categorize as
awful but lawful conduct listen if he's
out there advocating for Muller's
witnesses to obstruct justice then maybe
the Muellers to speak to him and ask him
where the idea come from have you spoken
to the president about this so the
president tell you to say this knowing
Moeller I think he's not going to light
that fire under someone who gets free
airtime every day but but what angle
what angle would be to say yeah look I'm
going to I'm going to a judge and I'm
gonna have you see I'm gonna have you
cease and desist this activity on
national television secondly I want to
talk to you and see if Trump has gotten
this idea from you or vice-versa
yeah words better if I advised them oh
and by the way it's really dumb it's not
gonna work out well for you you know the
great irony in all this is that they're
more angry that I was basically saying
that everything Hillary Clinton did it
all she did every bit of it
and by the way I love the idea I've
actually liked to meet Robert Muller's
Mary brand a Democratic donors I'd like
to meet Andrew Weissman I'd like to meet
the guy that lost to the Supreme Court
and I know put innocent people in jail
for a year to be overturned by the Fifth
Circuit that was excoriated by judges
not once but twice for withholding
Ixtapa Tory evidence and costing tens of
thousands of people jobs I have
questions for him I have questions for
Jeanne ray I have questions for Bob
Butler call me now let's get this
straight the mainstream media would put
me under investigation lock me up for
merely highlighting in an obviously
sarcastic
way the double standard and what I have
been pointing out our two-tier justice
system and these same people didn't get
the fact that Hillary had actually done
all of that she wiped away acid washed
her hard drive deleted 33,000 emails
that were subpoenaed she had an aide
smashing phones with a hammer and lied
about all of it that actually happened
they did all of this are you really that
dumb please tell me it's not true
now you would think on that one under
Muller some would be able to get away
with that okay just to be clear if the
bar but Muller asks for your phone don't
do what Hillary did as I said last night
it's not gonna end well for you you
won't get the same treatment which was
the point of it now the media when you
think they hit a new low they just dig
and dig and dig you can't believe this
you can't make it up all right one more
quick news story here the media is
probably hates to cover the president
granting clemency this is a beautiful
story woman's name is Alice Johnson
great-grandmother sentenced to life in
prison for one nonviolent drug crime
okay 20-some odd years in jail her first
day of freedom in 20 years she thanks to
President moments ago she spoke with her
own martha maccallum take a look the
only way that i was able to make it
through that time and this is the truth
was my faith in god i knew that one day
he was going to bring me out and i lived
my life with an eye toward one day
walking out of those doors a free woman
and the day that I got the news of
President Trump granted by clemency and
giving me a second chance at life was
the best day of my life god bless you we
wish you all the best and you know what
I think there's more of these cases we
can find give people second chances I
believe in them